on en a parlé la semaine dernière elle a
débarqué à paris à l'occasion de la
fashion week et depuis son arrivée et
bien elle fait tout pour se faire
remarquer looks extravagants des baskets
et aux interviews décalées
aucune de ses apparitions ne laisse
indifférent tel point qu'on se demande
s'il n'est pas en train de péter les
plombs regarder le sujet c'est
incroyable et puis d'ailleurs on aura
des infos elle à paris céline était à
paris ces derniers jours une vraie
tornade céline ampleur à la fashion week
céline est fort et qu'on nous le rouge
au milieu du public s'il y une passe du
rire aux larmes et se met à chanter
n'importe quoi à la vie à paris c'est
l'une des barres quand je marche se
promène en jaune canari invente des
blues improbable nous fait flipper avec
son extrême maigreur m'explique
enfin ce qui lui arrive je chante
toujours mais je m'adresse aussi voilà à
50 ans céline se lâche enfin
après tant d'années à tout contrôler vos
souvenirs lors de la libération
même fait son apparition pépé mine aux
34 ans danseur et styliste beau comme un
dieu mais attention précise la
québécoise qui lie un autre homme dans
ma vie mais ce n'est pas l'homme de ma
vie
dorénavant la règle du jeu ce sera non
plus on voit en fût c'est la fête
on découvre aujourd'hui une femme avec
un humour incroyable autant aucun
contrôlable elle s'imagine même déjà
poursuivi par toutes les polices du
monde alors céline at-elle pété les
plombs du hockey solide
à
[Applaudissements]
c'est un truc que je vous donne ça dans
une soirée vous avez un petit doute sur
un copain ce qui les pousse un petit peu
gay ou pas vous lancer un petit céline
si ça commence à bien en chef et que
vous êtes une meuf arrêté
pas plus loin
pas par les amis céline est elle en
train de péter les plombs c'est
hallucinant on fume on boit on a vu deux
soirées parisiennes la semaine dernière
dans une boîte très connu paraît-il même
elle titube et un petit peu face est
assez hallucinant et je vais donner la
parole d'abord à quelqu'un qui fait la
gueule depuis le début d'émission parce
que pendant la pub l ai dit oui je ne
parle pas on me demandait rien au café
la tête elle fait la tête mais tu parles
pas mon choix on a besoin de bonnes
audiences
magali bébé est ce qu'elle est en train
de péter les plombs tu dis oui belle en
train de péter les plombs c'est normal
elle fait sa crise est là elle a pas
vécu pendant des années parce qu'elle
était dans son petit cocon mais
maintenant elle est heureuse et épanouie
moi c'est pas heureuse avec renard comme
ça 6 mais en fait elle se libère là on
dirait qu'elle est une fée pas on la
voit si c'est extraordinaire moi j'adore
mais je suis fan de céline dion
maintenant elle et j'ai l'impression
qu'elle donne même envie de danser tous
très bien sébastien vous qui la
connaissaient mais c'est un peu la veuve
joyeuse elle a été sous la coupe de
drones et qui est beaucoup plus âgée et
austère pendant depuis qu'elle a l'âge
de 14 ans ouais makhoul a donc elle a eu
sa période de deuil ou uniquement elle
était à plat et maintenant elle
redécouvre une vie totalement nouvelle à
la fin une interview dans le sun hier ou
avant-hier où elle explique qu'elle est
à la meilleure période de sa vie qu'elle
pense toujours
et effectivement à rodez mais qu'on
avait la meilleure période de sa vie que
pépé c'est juste un pote et maintenant s
éclate et que pépé l'emmène dans les
squares et branchouille et sézanne et
manor et senna d'autre que sa rue main
elle passe du rire aux larmes elle a
tous les symptômes de la dépression
enfin franchement c'est assez c'est
assez bizarre il ya quelques années vous
mettiez pas vous pouvez pas fumer à côté
d'elle sans qu'elle pique une crise là
elle va en boîte un coup elle pleure à
quoi elle rit enfin franchement c'est
toujours été comme ça alors catherine et
l'activité elle a toujours eu ce
caractère comme ça te passer du rire aux
larmes qui est tel que kayak là pour les
pour les réfugiés tout ça quand tu es
plus régalé à toujours été un peu et la
maintenance avec elle elle exulte
quelque part c'est vrai parce que on
pensait qu'après rené ferez rien qu'elle
arrêterait tout pour ces mêmes qu'à
chanter pour lui faire plaisir que
limiter la force à elle est sur scène
parce que c'est vrai petit gagnante la
killer amis du pognon n'ont pas assez
fait réellement mais c'est vrai et
finalement on se rend compte que pas du
tout
non mais c'est une bagnole pour nous un
gage que l'udc et closer c'est ça qui
l'a forcé puis elle le disait j'en ai
marre de chanter moi je m'occupe de mes
enfants j'ai assez d'argent pour vingt
quatrième chez maintenant elle continue
de chanter elle fait de la mode elle va
donner au défilé elle a repris le goût
de la vie et on se rend compte que même
sans lui elle arrive à avoir mis le
projet et qu'elle a encore plus tard
qu'avant oui elle nous serons nous va le
faire la carrière qu'elle a fait ce sont
des carrières où il n'y a pas une once
de liberté d'improvisation bien sûr que
cette fille pendant des années a vécu un
an par le temps mais limiterait à des
années qu'elle était lavé son mari qui
était aussi son imprésario sans manager
dans quel fils et à ses droits et je
pense que là à 50 balais elle a envie de
vivre un petit peu et qu'elle découvre
un peu la vraie vie je pense que la wii
c'est bien d'en but est de jouer au
tennis ne s'est pas improvisé
c'était un gentil pour avoir une
anecdote très courte quand j'ai tourné
avec elle sur nrj 12
elle est arrivée si quelqu'un veut fumer
une cigarette même dans les deux heures
dans les deux heures avant que ça
pouvait sentir sur une veste elle peut
et piqué une crise quand je la vois dire
aujourd'hui où en bois on s'éclate on
fume
j'hallucine mais bon c'est peut-être ça
la crise de la cinquantaine
vous pouvez en témoigner catherine
ça nous arrivera un jour et puis la
crise de la soixantaine aussi un jour où
ça va nous arriver
bien sûr